(audience clapping)
I feel like we are all rocking this autumnal,
almost Thanksgiving.
We're color coordinated.
We look like fall, everybody, even though it's maybe winter,
I don't know.
It doesn't even matter.
The days are all blurring into each other at this point.
And we're pretty much living our life,
just like we are right now, on Zoom.
So if there's some connection, some symmetry, some uniting,
some togetherness,
this is not only as good as it's going to get right now,
but I would take this any day.
This is wonderful to be here with you guys, truly.
And tomorrow is Thanksgiving.
And even though Thanksgiving looks and feels so different
this year.
It just really does.
I've had to have a lot of internal dialogue
about this is one year.
It's a little bit of that one step at a time, day by day,
this is not forever.
This was not last year. It may not be next year.
In fact, I do think of all the Thanksgiving expectations
and traditions, when it gets down to that core moment
of what are you thankful for,
specially when you see kids do it.
Oh my goodness.
That really may be the moment
of what it's supposed to all be about.
I am certainly thankful for you today.
I am certainly thankful that we get to be at a job
and with each other here on this set.
It is a miracle.
We never take it for granted.
I want to check in with a VFF named Rocky
because, (gasps) because now you can see why.
Hi there.
Hi Rocky.
Who's your friend?
This is Mary, and Mary is a rescued turkey.
Mary doesn't have functional legs.
She just gets to be in a little throne all day.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, special Mary.
What made you fall in love with Mary?
Yeah, so Mary just really, truly
has an incredible personality.
In many ways, she's a lot like a puppy.
She is just very, very outgoing.
She forms really, really strong friendships.
Just very curious.
She always perks up whenever anyone comes onto the screen
and as you can see, she really loves cuddles.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, she's so sweet.
And she looks very like Etsy cool, I might add.
She's looking a little Brooklyn.
And I was wondering if I could show you
a pickie of my chickies.
Now, I know chickens and turkeys are not the same thing,
but I'm just saying, on your left,
that's Blanche, and that's Ramona behind her.
In the middle is Ferdinand.
And then I think the third picture
is just me giving them some corn.
Oh, that's Pepper on the left now.
And then that's Sparkles in the middle.
Oh, and there's Ramona.
She's a real looker.
But I just have to say I'm really into cuddling
with a feathery friend.
So I'm just saying, I feel ya.
You're welcome over anytime to come cuddle with Mary.
Well, maybe I'll bring the chickies, and we'll come visit.
And I'm just so glad that you are giving all of this love
to a little creature that needs it.
It's really special.
So thank you.
Thanks for showing the love.
(upbeat music)